فشلت المحاولات لتشريع قانون الميراث
للاردنيين المسيحيين بسبب معارضه نواب
ورجال دين واردونيين يرفضون التخلي عن
مكتسبات ذكوريه تاريخيه لمصلحه المراه في
العائله انا شخصيا
منعاني من بكره الصبح يرجع كل اشي باسم
البنات لانه اللي بلش فيهن ابوهم انا حاب
اكمله هذا القانون تم مراجعته
ووضعه بصيغه شبه نهائيه وتم رفعه لجميع
رؤساء الطوائف في الاردن
ولا بال الكنائس في الاردن نفضل ان نستخدم
هذا المصطلح ولاول مره في تاريخ الاردن
توضع مسوده قانون للميراث وهاي المسوده
اعتقد انها ستساعد في البناء والاستمرار
للامام وهذه المسوده تم نشرها في هذا
الكتاب
وايضا قدمت للرؤساء مجلس رؤساء الطوائف
والمسائل الكنائس في الاردن
وهكذا استمر حرمان مسيحيات الاردن على وقع
فيتو ثلاثي غير معلن رفض كناسي جزئي عرف
ذكوري مجتمعي وحياد حكومي على الرغم من ان
هناك رغبه من اغلب الاردنيين المسيحيين في
تعديل قانون الميراث المسيحي
[موسيقى]